we can check this one who is the domain
for stop big con was registered on 12 12
2022.
who is.com stop VidCon was registered on
12 12. internet sleuths are going to
catch them Crowder announces he left the
Blaze and asks people to sign up for mug
Club on 12 15 2022. it was all like the
fact like listen I love the internet
slues because this is of course was
going to happen and this is the problem
is that Steven has to realize people are
smart Okay people are smart they're
gonna figure it out oh so you happened
to look up the to to register big Connie
yeah let's confirm that what's that yeah
I got it right
vidcon.com right now we are 12 12 20 22.
so this was this was registered stop
VidCon was registered before he
announced he was leaving the blaze is
that what it was that's so weird he
announced he was leaving The Blaze on
12th well guys and again Crowder will be
here on Monday he can tell us about all
this I don't want um and then he
recorded his conversation with Jeremy
two months after that I just want to say
like we're we're we're we're in the
middle as per usual Candace was booked a
month and a half ago you know and this
whole drama lights up and then we talked
with Crowder uh we we asked him to come
on and talk about this so I mean there
are so many things that I disagree with
the daily wire on like so many things
this is just not one of them like this
is just actually someone's being a bad
person and plotting against them that's
it that's all that's all this is right
and that's what I want to say because
like I said before I've been together
for three years you've never heard me
come out and defend them but they're in
trouble every other week with a
different host for something that they
said something they haven't said Ben
Shapiro's Under Fire at least once a
week on Twitter people are angry at him
I think it's a show for this but I don't
wait on anything this actually Stephen
Crowder is a bad person I was thinking
what if they just paid Steven 50 million
for his back catalog and then put it on
daily wire exclusive and the only way to
see Steven is to go to daily wire like
that would I don't know 50 million would
be worth it but four-year terms I had a
lawyer you could negotiate or you could
go what if you could go into
dailywire.com and then pay 99 cents on a
Crowder video to watch it for the day
and then Steven gets half the revenue or
something I mean there's so many cool
things we could do I mean things could
do it would require Stephen to just look
at the con the term sheet and then be
like I'd rather do it this way here you
go there you go a conversation he's got
I'm interested to talk to him Stephen
because I think he's got specific
feelings and perspectives on what big
Tech censorship can do to a content
creator that needs to be vocalized for
future contract negotiations I've been
concerned about contracts especially
with like perpetuity Clauses like we own
your likeness forever in every Universe
going forward they'll they'll deep fake
you and make you say things with deep
fakes becoming so realistic they'll own
your face and your name and it's crazy
we need to get perpetuity Clauses for
characters out of of her personality out
of contract I think so right now I want
to say this like I don't they've always
got a lot of haters and I can certainly
understand not liking the daily wire or
not liking certain personalities I know
people who are like I love Clavin I
don't like Ben Shapiro yeah I know
people who are like I only watch Candace
I won't watch anybody else I think
everyone else is bad and I'm like okay
but like that should say that like we
don't all agree on everything but daily
wire existing is a massive net positive
regardless of whether you like what
they're doing or not like just again
what is a woman was a massive cultural
force and that matters so much which we
talk about culture and the importance of
cultural dominance so much that
documentary reached regular people it
was so big I mean I I regular people I
know were like oh I saw that thing that
was going viral and I'm like hey that's
good do more of that I don't got I don't
got to go work for him Crowders have to
go work for you guys work for I should
say you guys but for Jeremy or anything
like that but and that's why it's so
crappy to paint a broad stroke you know
paint with a broad stroke and say the
daily wire is this because you're
attacking that well that's just nothing
to do with Stephen card I have nothing
to do with Stephen Crowder and yet
you're basically making it seem like
we're all plants that we've done
something wrong and that it's that's
deeply upsetting to me it's super
annoying to me I would like to see
people stop saying that company is doing
thing because it's people the people are
doing the thing with the guys of the
company attempting to protect their
their person you know their identity but
like no companies don't do things so
fair point someone mentioned Crowder
never said the daily wire okay but like
the shmeli schmeyer I mean how many
freaking all of the context clues were
it's like this is the crap the acting of
like I'm not gonna say it was but I am
going to make sure you know that it's
not the blaze they have a subscription
service and that there are live ad reads
and that they could afford to put enough
money on a contract that I would have a
conversation does your character have
glasses yeah exactly
like literally this is this is such a
ridiculous defense in four seconds you
can discern this is about daily wire
can't be Fox News they don't have live
ad reads he already told you that it's
not the blaze what does that leave us
left with
didn't you say that you also recognized
the contract Fox News before he got to
it I mean when you say live ad reads a
subscription service you can't be Fox
News because he's already left them and
talks trash with them the whole time and
they don't do live ad reads right who
else could it have been just give me
another clue who else would have been
prageru 501c3 not for profit can't have
been them can't can't be give me a
person it could have been so that's what
everybody was saying yeah the daily Wire
yeah so when I never said a name it's
like what do you think about this I
think this was a bad move on daily wires
part that the contract said if you get
demonetized there will be a fee but
Crowders already demonetized they had I
told you they had these same this is why
I'm saying this was just a conversation
starter they had these same things that
made no literally entirely no sense in
my contract I was it literally I was
like okay is this you guys like a lawyer
just like copy and paste this from
somebody else's contract like if this is
just a conversation starter like they
just want you to see the number and go
I'm excited and bring your lawyers in
right there were literally things that
were saying like I'm not on Tick Tock
they mentioned my Tick Tock they
mentioned my Snapchat uh and I was like
okay well I'm on any of these things and
I'm never planning on being on them so
we can strike this strike this and and
you know and then you add and then you
say okay this one sounds okay can we
include an extra line here like he kind
of started this idea that my
um my social media channels are
controlled literally they had something
about access to my Twitter check it out
I said I will never ever ever my Twitter
is how I made my entire brand I will
never even share a login to my Twitter
right and then my Instagram same exact
thing and so they created a separate
Instagram which they're allowed to do
which has canason's pod and it has its
own followers and they release stuff
from the podcast I didn't want to sell
my voice you know my social media things
it would have been nice for them to have
access but it's actually better for them
because then they can own that page in
perpetuity Candace Owens podcast because
I'm creating content for them so they
can share clips into perpetuity of what
I have they have paid for right so it's
like that's again just there he's
pretending that there was something
nefarious going on there I got the same
stuff that made no sense you'd say just
like you said this makes no sense
because I'm already demonetized from
YouTube that was my circumstance for
Facebook I was all they had a thing
about demonization for Facebook my
lawyer went back and said cash is
already demonetized on Facebook and they
went oh that's right strike it from the
claws
you know for people asking too like yeah
when Crowder comes on I'm gonna let him
again say his piece I'm not you know
like Candace is giving her perspective
working the daily wire and what I want
them to cook contract negotiation so
there's no way that he can pretend that
there's something missing he didn't go
through them he went through term sheet
don't like 140 million dollars I'm going
on to YouTube I went through the full
five month negotiation so there's
nothing for me to make up here you know
what I mean someone said what if Crowder
and the daily wire planned this for
attention
I love a good conspiracy theory the the
Jeremy the Jeremy response video was
recorded December 3rd
I love that I don't know look look again
I'll say it again Crowder's not here to
defend himself you know so you know he's
on YouTube on YouTube how do you really
feel
but uh but look man I'll I'll wrap up
with this and we'll move on to some big
worldly things with like the world I can
make for him Alec Baldwin we got to talk
about Alec Baldwin uh
I I I look I I negotiated with the daily
wire on on like here's what happens you
know Jeremy comes on the show and he
says is there is there anything we can
do together and I'm like he's like
because I know you you do a company and
it's not the same as like if we went to
any other person and said come work for
us and I was like there's probably
something we could work out look there's
a lot of stuff I don't know and we're
trying to build this thing we're trying
to do X Y and Z we're trying to do
cultural stuff I know you guys are we
talked we went back and forth and I said
guys I don't think there's anything here
and uh Jeremy was like I think you're
right we went over numbers we know
everything and uh the daily wire said
what if we did this and I said
it doesn't work it doesn't work for what
we're doing because we want to do these
things and um I'm just going to come out
and say this you know I try to keep
private details but I said I said Jeremy
like I might want to buy a billboard
that says Liz Cheney's a fat pig you
know what I mean like I know that like
the daily and he was and he started
laughing and he went well I don't know
about that and I'm like look we're we're
crazy weirdo Rogues what we do at Tim
cast we we want to be be nuts and we
want to look not crazy crazy but we want
to just be we're we're not the suits and
we're not the corporation
but I think what you guys are making is
good because your version of the
corporation is better than the Disney
version of the corporation but I'm not
the corporation either and I want to
make that very clear and that's what
annoys me is that people just they have
this idea of what the daily wire is and
then they try to say that every single
host exists on this idea we disagree all
the time like there's literally it's
hard to find a moment where me and Ben
Crossing agree on but you know what I'm
saying and so they paint this thing of
like there is no like yes the office is
very I don't even go into the office
there's a podcast Studio that I go into
that is smaller than this that I that I
operate within so it's just it's very
frustrating because people just don't
understand yes he is running his
business and there's a corporate side of
the daily wire and it's annoying to me
to have to though answer for people that
thinking that that somehow corporatizes
can of zones I've been the exact same
Candace Owens from the beginning of my
YouTube days to now but I'm not trying
to imply anything about you or any of
the hosts I mean like they they it's
it's it's a traditional Corporation it's
got personalities of varying opinions
and like us putting a 95-foot billboard
of a rooster and one of the biggest
Times Square Billboards makes no sense
as a business but it makes sense
culturally and it makes sense you know
like we want want to we want to be more
shocking and the daily wire wants to
beat Disney at their game you know we do
to a certain degree but I don't think
you know I look I think maybe in 10
years we can have some kind of network
that'll have a cultural Force that's a
good thing I think the daily wire the
way it's structured actually is set up
to poach the content to poach the
executives to poach the talent from
these industries of course that makes
you similar in some ways but the output
is corrected you know what I mean that's
why I like the daily wire you know uh
despite not wanting to work for the
daily wire but at the end you know I my
my thing with Jeremy was like I don't
think there's anything we could do
transactionally but there's a lot we can
do culturally for fun yeah and so we're
actually working on some stuff and and
the same thing is true like you know I
talked to Crowder all the time about
Russians all the time but periodically
we talk about culture War issues you
know what needs to be done what we can
do we've talked about the stuff that
Ian's working on with a decentralized
network yeah I got a new company a
relatively new called inverted
Technologies and we're building like
basically what patreon attempted to do
or didn't quite get right but that you
you basically upload you download a
packet software packet you load the
application you can upload videos to a
server of your choice once you have your
house you can upload it to rumble and
then you can get yours all these people
can pay 10 bucks a month whatever you
want different tiers of payments to get
access to that content and later as we
build this out it's going to have search
algorithms where you can find other
people other content creators that are
using it and create a network where
everyone owns their own stuff you can't
be banned the idea is like your website
can also have a recommended section of
similar content and you as the website
owner so like let's say we did
timcast.com and we we joined this
network you will see in the recommended
tab Stephen Crowder I could go look I
don't want you know as a competitor and
unlike his opinion so I'm going to say
on my website he can't appear but he's
not banned from the network just my
personal site so basically you create a
decentralized that's awesome the idea
would be you launch you you buy your own
server time space for or you make your
own server you set you buy your own
domain and then you download the package
install it on your server and you
instantly have your own patreon that
connects to the network of all the other
people using it for recommendation
reasons because the recommendation is
the real driver of so much of of
everyone's of people if you make good
content and you make a lot of it and it
rises to the top
people will see it and that's the
machine that needs to happen so so but
when YouTube bans you out right you're
gone from the grid when they Shadow ban
you you're gone from the grid this way
you can't do this anyway I've talked
about stuff like that and I want to see
him succeed I uh I I would prefer that
you know the conflict the arguing or
whatever wasn't wasn't happening but
look I talked to Stephen I I genuinely
believe that he thinks daily wires are
not negative in the space I don't think
he's doing this for money uh you're
entitled to your opinion I understand
your perspective I've talked to him
about it and he said that you know these
kinds of contracts are I'll paraphrase
my understanding the Old Guard System
created the problems we whatever we're
building has to be new and it has to be
different it has to be better and it's
funny because when I when I do deals
with people I joke that I'm a communist
and that's why they're getting such good
terms when I when I when I talk with
Jeremy boring I'm like this guy's a
businessman who's trying to make sure no
one can stab him in the back the fact
the fact is I think Stephen Crowder
doesn't know this because he hasn't
started a business but I've been stabbed
in the back like 73 times and it sucks
every time and I lose money every time
and my my safety is threatened every
time but you know like I jokingly say
I'm a communist so blah blah blah not
literally but when I'm when I'm trying
to convey by that is I'm still willing
to to over uh extend myself if it means
we're going to get better people and
that's the system I'm gonna build I
don't fault the daily wire for running
their business The Way businesses run I
like the content the daily wire produces
I just won't be there when they produce
it wonderful you're Market capitalist
your idea is that if you believe that
you have something better or you can do
something better you create the
something better take out the old guys I
mean like is that a foreign concept is
that has this become a foreign concept
like do do we have to all be so nasty to
me I just don't get it because I've
never since I've gotten into politics
I've never understood the mentality that
you need to step on someone's head to go
where like oh I just need to step on
this person's head so that I can move
Upstream it's like why don't you learn
to swim if you want to go Upstream you
know why don't you want to swim and
tread some water if you want to go
Upstream what is this what for a little
bit of oh I'm going to burn friendships
you keep calling them your friend I I it
doesn't make any sense to me I'll I'll
say my final thought on this I suppose
and then again Crowder will be here on
Monday we'll have a conversation from
his perspective
yo if you're gonna stop anybody I don't
understand why going after the daily
wire is the first Target even if the
daily wire was doing these really awful
contracts like or I should say they're
doing term sheets they're doing
Contracting in ways you don't like I
still think it's like well okay well at
least they made what is a woman let's
focus on Disney and Netflix Netflix has
done a bunch of pedo stuff you know what
I mean like a deadly wire is just not a
concern for me even if I was going to
come out and be like 49 of the business
dealings the daily wire I don't like but
51 is good then I'd be like I'll take
that one percent and I'll focus on
Netflix doing weird pedo crap yeah but I
actually think the daily wire is much
better than that I just it's not my kind
of business style so you know I hope I
hope Crowder
um just does his thing and succeeds and
and I I think it's simple you know if it
were me and I really did see the daily
wires and net negative I'll put it this
way I mean I talk about Disney all the
time I say I don't expect you to abandon
your Disney subscriptions because they
have Flubber they have movies you know
and love I just hope to build a better
website that eventually produces enough
to where you say I'd rather not have
Disney that that's my strategy but again
guys I'm I'm the milk milk toast Fun
Center I'm the reformer not a
revolutionary I'm not going to come out
smash the ball on the ground and be like
I will stand for nothing I'm going to
sit here and I'm gonna do the math I'm
going to go daily wire is doing pretty
good you know I might not like that but
that's that's good for us so okay
where's our where's our net problem I'm
I'm much more slow slow paced and
calculate you know calculating than that
I think if the daily wire succeeds we
all succeed and then when Disney's gone
when Netflix is gone when Amazon Prime
is gone assuming and the daily wire is
the only one then we can start saying
daily why are you do better deals with
your with your employees and then the
daily wire is going to be like you know
either do it or don't my take is I'm
glad the conversation is happening
um I think that Jeremy and Stephen have
have seen each other as friends is
important because sometimes easiest to
criticize your friends it's easier to
criticize your friends than people that
might go sue you and don't have any
connection to you at all and and that
daily wire is gaining a lot of steam and
becoming larger and larger so if there
really are problems with the contracts
or the terms off the bat it's important
that they know that right away from
people with you know large levels of
influence thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time